superannuation um
sometimes sort of synonymously referred
to as a
pension right it's this whole idea of
hey man you've only got this certain
period of your life
where you can work enough to have an
income but then
thanks to the wonders of modern health
and medicine you're actually going to
stay alive
for a while after that but not have
continued work that will earn you money
so we want to make sure you've got
something to draw on that can enable you
to survive
financially whilst not working
okay so a pension is what we call that
the way that we build it is by this
mechanism superannuation and thankfully
kind of the name itself tells you what
it is let's go with the easy part first
annuation annual when something is
annual it is
one year right or every year right it's
like oh i go on an annual
business trip to somewhere okay so this
is something that's happening
generally speaking on a yearly basis
hello are you looking for
period for
just one second uh
[Applause]
it warrants some explanation just one
second
um
i knew we were talking about this topic
i just more specifically
okay very good it's an annual thing
right usually and then
super when you see the prefix super on
something
we actually don't think about the
meaning of that where you're like oh
super is good right
more specifically thank you very much
what does it mean
boost this is actually not that bad a
way to think about it
super mean we usually think something
super is good
but some words help us know better like
a superintendent
superintendent it's a it's a job it's
someone who's
it's above right it's something that's
bigger so like superman is like oh he's
bigger and better and everything like
that
so this whole idea of you have this sum
of money
right and every year it gets bigger and
bigger you add to it and you put on top
every single time something which you
can then draw on in the future right
does that make sense
so this is like your retirement fund
you're saving you're not taking money
out of it
hopefully this year has been a tough
year for people and their finances so we
actually have all kinds of issues with
that
but this idea of superannuation is
something we've entrenched in law okay
when you get a job your employer in
australia anyway
is required to put money aside
for you that you can't touch it goes
into your
pension into your superannuation scheme
and then it stays there until such a
point as you retire and then you can
access it or if some other kind of
emergency
emerges okay now what does this have to
do
with what we've been looking at before
well compound interest is normally how
we think about saving money
right and we know in compound interest
your amount we looked at yesterday right
we have a formula for this how do we
calculate it
what comes first it's p for principal
the amount of money you put in then
brackets what's in the brackets
one plus r so there's some interest rate
and then to the power of n so the
presumption here is you take your amount
of money
put it in and then you just wait and it
grows interest okay
but what we're doing is we're taking
that idea and extending it what if we
didn't just put a
single sum of money in and let it grow
interest
what if we actually did that and then
next year we did it again
and then the year after that we did it
again okay
so to explore that let's have a look at
this question together
um you've got these two people both
named robin for some reason
and they are investing ten thousand
dollars
in a superannuation scheme okay so let's
start to unpack the information that's
important and write it down
um that ten thousand dollars that
they're investing annually we have a
name for this that i don't
think is said in the question it's
called an installment
so an annual installment
in this case is ten thousand dollars as
you can imagine that's going to be an
important piece of information for us to
solve the questions that are coming
so you've got an annual installment ten
thousand dollars goes in every single
year
when does it begin it begins on the 1st
of july each year
in the year 2000 okay so we start
at the 1st of july 2000
okay they'll often give you some
information here about the dates so you
can know when exactly things begin
and you can see at the end in these
questions
the dates matter right they start
talking about the 30th of june and all
that we'll come to that in a minute
the money earns compound interest at
eight percent per annum
compounded annually so we looked at
compounding periods before
this is keeping it pretty simple just
once per year so we don't need to do any
division or multiplication that kind of
thing but we do need to write down
the interest rate
is eight percent per annum
and because i'm so um i know of myself
that i often forget
when uh it's compounded at a different
time that to change those numbers
even though it's compounded annually
which is like no change i'm still going
to write that down
okay so i'm just going to put that in
brackets compounded
i'm really messy today annually
okay happy times have a look at the
question have we got all the key details
that's mostly okay right so now they
then start to ask us well of this
situation
what happens as we go forward in time
the first question says
how much will the fund amount to by the
30th of june
2020 30th of june 2020. why is the 30th
of june an important
date in a financial year
right and then when you have a look at
this specific question it also has
relevance to the dates
mentioned here right yeah it's a whole
year it's the 30th of june is one day
before
presumably they would put in another
installment does that make sense
if they looked at the first of july on
that day um another ten thousand dollars
would have gone in
okay but we're considering some ten
thousand dollars going in and then the
whole year has elapsed
okay now the way we're going to form
this and you'll see why we introduced
this in the topic that we did
is to try and establish a pattern okay
so i'm going to say
let a zero you know how we've got this a
here right and it's just an amount after
some amount of time
i'm going to have several amounts for
different points in time so i'm going to
call them
a one two three four five actually i
shouldn't say a0 i should say a n
first that's the amount after n years
have passed okay
you can see i'm sort of mentioning this
because this other question that we're
going to get to later
asks for this expression okay so let's
let that
be the amount
saved you don't say any amount invested
because that's the ten thousand dollars
every single year
but then i saved the sort of total
amount after
n years we're going to use this
a n notation so now this is what i was
getting to before
where does it all begin a0 after no
years have passed
well what's the first thing that begins
this superannuation
yeah it's the first installment ten
thousand dollars goes in and so
that's what happens no time has actually
elapsed so no
interest has been earned on this so far
so good okay
so then we start to establish a pattern
by thinking about what happens year by
year so now i go
to the following year a1 okay so
this is now if you want to put it in
brackets on the side here this is year
2001
one year after the first installment
goes in
what happens hmm 12 months pass yep
okay let me fill that in oops
i think that's what we said right you've
got your principal that the
the interest is being applied to there's
your interest and there's how long
it went for because it's one year right
however you can see because we're doing
we're sort of building this one year at
a time doing it nice and slow
i can kind of just simplify that to be
that 10 000
from the previous year and then it just
got interest
is that okay